In this section of the course,
we're gonna go over Nanite and Virtual Shadow Maps.
So let's go ahead and get started.
So many people will ask, what is Nanite exactly?
Well, it's Unreal 5's virtualized geometry system.
So it's stored as a hierarchical system
of smaller parts using triangles.
It adds geometric complexity with less issues.
So you can think of it as it's drawing
the geometry complexity as needed
and putting the rest in a catch.
Nanite allows for higher visual fidelity
and works well with Lumen.
So it's ideal to pair those up.
Outside of Lumen, the generating of shadow maps,
such as baking, will take too long on a complicated mesh.
So you have to be careful with it.
Doesn't mean you can't use Nanite
within the old school baking method.
It's just not ideal, especially when you can get
the performance you get out of Lumen
and you can update your lighting on the fly.
Virtual shadow maps are used for more realistic results.
So virtual shadow maps pairs with Nanite
and pairs with Lumen.
Again, you can think of it as the three musketeers.
They're the best approaches for using the,
they're getting the best visual fidelity you can
and getting it updated quickly and efficiently.
Instance, object, count and draw calls
are less of a limitation when you're using this system.
Now instances are in the millions.
Auto LODs and streaming uses clusters of data.
So it's kind of like virtual texturing.
Virtual texturing calls upon the textures,
the higher resolution when needed
based on the position of yourself in the world.
The same thing with Nanite.
It calls upon the higher visual fidelity of that object
when you are positioned in the right spot.
So it's not gonna be drawing it all the time.
So visually and efficiently working with Lumen
and virtual shadow maps,
it works great.
So you'll see down below the last note here
is more visually accurate than displacement
with less shadow artifacts.
So let's talk about that for a second.
So displacement is inaccurate
with extreme shadowing changes
and light changes with higher displacement values
due to going beyond the object's original bounds.
Now you'll notice every object has a bounds limit.
If you simply type that in,
in the search and the details,
you will find the bounds.
Let me show you just for a second.
So you see in Unreal, I've selected this object.
If I simply type in bounds,
you'll see that there's a bound scale.
So if I had more surface detail on here
and a displacement active,
I would have to increase this if I'm noticing
that there's maybe some graphical weird issues going on,
or I just want that displacement
to be a little bit more accurate.
And what I mean by graphical distortion
is sometimes when you put a displacement
and the bounds isn't high enough,
it won't know how to draw the surface new shape
that you've put in here in the material
versus the original shape.
That's what the bounds scale comes in for.
So the shadows can become inaccurate
with that surface detail.
I don't have a high surface detail
with a displacement active,
but you kind of get the point.
So you want to avoid those weird artifacts
and the shadows that can happen when using displacement.
So Nanite's there to kind of solve that.
Nanite is great for high resolution model shadowing
and it keeps accuracy working with the virtual shadow maps.
You're going to see off to the right here,
two demonstrations, two images that show that in action.
Here's kind of like a default,
trying to use a displacement.
And you know, maybe not as much detail on this model.
Here we have a Nanite object
using virtual shadow maps on the bottom
and you'll see it looks much, much better.
It looks really, really great.
You can also use Nanite for ICV effects if you need to.
So Nanite now supports explicit tangents
in the data format and runtime.
So you're going to get more accuracy.
So before Nanite used to rely on a tangent space
that is implicitly derived in the material.
So it would be strictly in the material front
based on the screen space position and UV gradients.
But now things are more explicit with the tangents
and the data format and runtime.
So it looks a lot better, supports those tangents.
Now let's take a look at using Nanite
and how to set it up.
It is really super easy.
And I'm going to show you some search options
that you can do to test
and see what things are not Nanite active,
quick and easy in the content browser.
Speaking of in the content browser,
at any time you can select any piece of geometry,
right click Nanite and activate it.
Let me show you real quick how to do it.
It's pretty simple.
So in Unreal, you'll see I have a piece of geometry
selected.
Let's go ahead and go to that folder
and find out where that's at.
Now, to be able to check on this piece of geometry,
I could right click and go to Nanite and activate it.
Let's open up a Nanite scene
a little bit more detail.
So you can kind of see,
you can kind of see that workflow.
In this scene, we have a few rocks
that are a bit more detail in here,
but maybe I've imported them from say, Quixel Bridge,
and I've chosen Nanite as an option.
Yes, in Quixel Bridge,
you can choose Nanite ahead of time.
When you go to import,
you can import anything at any time.
You can also turn on Nanite
when the import window shows up.
So with this object selected,
again, I can find it in my content browser.
I can right click and go to Nanite and activate Nanite.
You can also double click on the object itself.
And in here, just type in Nanite,
and we can make sure that we enable Nanite support.
This is gonna make sure that this object is correctly
being rendered using that Nanite data.
Now, in Unreal,
normally in the old school way of doing things,
we would have a method called LODs or level of detail
that's connected to geometry.
That occurs when Nanite isn't active.
If I was to turn Nanite off,
it would make it so that now we have a level of detail
based on camera distance.
But now with Nanite, our geometry is put into a catch
so that it's only drawing the high fidelity
when needed based on that distance.
Note in the number three here of my points,
if using chaos, active also in geo,
you wanna go to your collector's editor.
So you wanna go in there
and turn that on active within there.
Note also virtual textures are not required
to be used with Nanite,
but they are highly recommended
because then you're gonna be able to control,
especially if your world is huge,
you're gonna be able to control
that virtual texturing works just like you get
from Nanite where it actually controls
when the high resolution shows up
based on your positioning in the world.
So it's not gonna be trying everything at the same time.
So it's really super efficient.
So you're using Nanite, using virtual texturing,
you're using Lumen and you're using virtual shadow maps.
And all of these can marry together
to give you a better performance overall.
We've also added a fallback target setting
in the Nanite static meshes.
In this menu, it just allows you
and provides a more explicit control
over which target to reduce to for the fallback mesh.
So relative error or percentage triangles.
This is really used if you're having a little bit
of trouble with your high detailed mesh.
The auto should work fine by default,
but you have this option to be able to edit this
if you need to.
So let's go and take a look at trying to determine what,
say you have a huge scene, you put a bunch of geometry in
and you want to determine what's Nanite and what's not.
Now we used to have a menu before
in older versions of Unreal 5,
where you could actually have like,
it was kind of like a Nanite debug kind of thing,
kind of Nanite viewer.
But in this case, we can now find it pretty easy
just by punching in this particular text
inside the content browser.
We'll just do that real quick.
So if we go back to Unreal and I go to my content browser,
I can click on, let's go to the top of the content
folder, I can click on here and I can simply type in
my Nanite enabled, you'll see two equal signs
and then false.
What it is, it's looking for everything that is not Nanite
and you'll see I have a couple of things that aren't.
And that's a quick way to be able to find out
if you have something that you need to convert.
And believe it or not,
I can select multiple pieces at the same time,
right click and say convert to Nanite.
Now you'll notice if I convert say this particular one,
right click and I say convert to Nanite,
you'll notice there's an enable Nanite here.
So it's going to auto activate.
So if I click on Nanite, there it goes.
And that particular object's now become a Nanite object.
And I believe it was this little sucker here.
Let's go and find him in the content browser.
If I double click on him and type in Nanite,
we've made it now.
So some of this stuff will auto populate
and then we have enable Nanite support.
Cool.
One less thing for you to have to worry about.
Now let's take a brief look at virtual shadow maps
and what exactly they, what they are.
What they do on what they help with
is they significantly increase shadow resolution
to match highly detailed Nanite geometry.
So this is what I meant by them pairing together nicely.
Unlike shadow maps in the past, what we had for baking,
which are like texture projecting.
So it's like projects that shadow on the surface.
It's plausible soft shadows
with reasonable controllable performance costs
and provide a simple solution that works for default
with limited amounts of adjustments needed.
So it is now the default when you open up Unreal.
Now you still need to work with some settings and Lumen,
double checking if you're gonna work with them together,
make sure you're using hardware ray tracing
like we talked about before.
And you're gonna replace,
what it does, it also replaces many stationary lights
in the old school baking method,
shadowing technique with a single unified path.
So it makes it so it's a little bit managed,
a lot better managed, manageable in my humble opinion.
And I think it's really great to use.
It's simple, you get up and running quickly
and you can get some really nice visuals.
So made for Lumen mainly,
not intended for Unreal standard baking,
virtual shadow maps is strictly for the Lumen workflows.
If you wanna switch to baking,
you must change your shadow settings in the project
and make sure Lumen is completely turned off everywhere.
Also your light mobility needs to be changed
to a static or stationary, if you were to go that route.
But I highly recommend trying to stay within Lumen
cause it's really great.
We get into the baking method
in other more advanced classes,
if you decided you wanted to use that on some other level.
So virtual textures deal with similar issues
as virtual shadow maps and how they handle things.
Now, what that means is it's only gonna draw
like I mentioned before, the high fidelity
or the high quality things that you need.
And in this case, your high quality shadows
based on your position in the world.
It's not gonna try to project everything at all one time,
but it's gonna be working with this system in here.
It splits the texture and MIP chain into tiles
and streams in only once needed.
So that makes it a lot more efficient.
So you can see it works very much like virtual textures
or shuffling and only giving us what we need
based on where we're at in the world.
You'll see local lights, 16K by 16K,
virtual resolution with eight MIPs.
This is how local lights would work.
Spotlights use a single virtual shadow map,
point and rec lights use six virtual shadow maps,
one per cubic face.
Now, 2K more than conventional shadow maps
and unreal baked.
So you can still run out if you're not careful.
It's a lot more efficient,
but you can still run out of memory
if you're putting,
anytime you throw the kitchen sink at anything,
you can get things to go to a crawl,
but this is so much more efficient
and so much more excellent
when it comes to getting what you need visually,
quickly, fast,
and getting these guys running in the right direction.
So let's kind of have a little bit
of a comparable overview here.
We have directional light, 16K,
still nowhere near enough resolution.
We're getting there.
LOD takes advantage of the camera projection expanding.
So it's getting better and better.
Shadow comparisons.
Let's talk about this, the old versus the new.
MIP maps all cover the same world area,
but half the resolution.
Clip map levels are all 16K,
but cover double the area.
So you can see right there
where the efficiency and quality can be seen.
The concept.
Clip map levels are centered around a clip map origin.
An example, the camera.
And this is what I meant by drawing
what you need at that particular time.
Each clip map level is snapped
such that the pages fall on the grid.
This is very convenient for catching and LOD fallbacks.
They can see that virtual shadow maps
allow for more precise control and realism.
Now let's take a look at some editing we can do.
So you don't always have to do this
because the defaults work pretty well,
but you do have the option to use console variables here
to be able to edit your shadows
on a kind of a low level.
So we have our shadow virtual SMRT rate count local
and our shadow virtual SMRT rate count direction
to adjust the number of rays in the penumbra.
Fewer rays, you get noise.
More rays is smoother and zero creates a hard shadow.
So these can be used to be able to edit things
if you need it.
You may not always,
cause you might be able to go into your,
you know, your source radius,
get it softer as you need.
But you know, these options are here.
Shadow ray samples can also be adjusted
via these commands too.
So shadow virtual SMRT samples per ray local
and shadow virtual SMRT samples per ray directional
to adjust the number of samples used
using the values between four, eight samples work well.
Just keep in mind though, the penumbra has limits,
but you can extend those limits also with these CVARS.
So local and directional lights
can use the console variables,
r.shadow.virtual SMRT max ray angle from the light
and r.shadow.virtual SMRT ray length scale directional
to loosen or tighten the clamp extents.
So you can do so, just be careful.
So you want to keep that penumbra size reasonable
or you will get a bad,
some really bad shadow artifacts and inconsistent areas.
So virtual shadow maps now respect
the Nanite call distance,
even when shadow catching is enabled.
So scenes relying on calling will now have faster shadows
but might see shadow artifacts
if the call distances are short enough
to see the popping in the primary render.
So you'll see there's a shadow catch invalidation behavior
and you'll see that it's set to auto
and auto typically works great,
but you do have some options here.
So a pre, you'll see a per primitive flag
that gives a user control over shadow invalidation behavior.
This provides users with a way to prevent invalidation.
For example, in the case where the primitive is known
to use the world position offset setting statically
or systems cannot deduce this automatically at present.
Our systems, I should say.
The default setting is auto,
which retains current behavior unless explicitly changed.
So you can find that in the object itself.
If I was to paste that information in there,
you'll see shadow catch invalidation behavior.
And there's always rigid and static.
And Unreal is really nice to break those down for you
and what scenarios you use them.
Auto typically works good, but we give you those options
so you feel drunk with power
and edit things accordingly.
So let's go ahead and take a look
at some of the visualizers.
You'll see we have a shadow mask.
We have a clip, map, mip level, a virtual page,
and a catched page.
You'll see back in Unreal that we can access these.
Oops, wrong there.
Let's go down to here.
This is where they're at.
And we go to virtual shadow map.
You'll see shadow mask.
There we go.
And we can switch to clip mip level
and we can go to virtual page.
See how that's being sourced.
And then we can do a catched page.
So those visualizers allow you to see
how that's being digested with our directional light
in this particular case.
That's it with this lecture.
Here's some links to help you get started
in understanding some of these concepts better.
In the next lesson,
I'm gonna walk you through step-by-step how to build
and get your lighting set up for a hero object.
Thanks again.